we have to check in with our friends
libs of tiktok there is a tick tock that
has gone viral of a young
woman
describing the national epidemic
of fat phobia
let's talk about body preferences i've
heard a lot of talk like oh i don't hate
fat people
but
i'm not attracted to them and i don't
want to date them it's just my
preference
maybe in an ideal circumstance
in a world
that was forever body neutral
and did not demonize fat people
that could be a preference
maybe
but is there really such a thing
as preference in a society
that exclusively demonizes
an option
fat people are branded as disgusting
branded as something to be eliminated
unhygienic
lazy xyz everything else and we've
received that messaging since we were
born our culture is deeply rooted and
entrenched in fatphobia chances are it's
not just a preference and you've just
been taught to think fat people are
gross
fat
phobia
everything is
a phobia
the line here that really caught my
attention is she said that we're taught
that fat people need to be eliminated
but what are you talking about not even
in the days of michelle obama who really
did seem to have a grudge against fat
people you know her big initiative in
the white house was was taking away
snacks from kids at lunch
taking away their little sweets in their
school lunches and making them eat
celery or whatever
uh but even in those days i don't think
anyone was calling for a genocide of fat
people do you remember that i don't
remember that then i thought what what
on earth could she mean but oh oh she
means
that people who are overweight are
encouraged to get into shape
that's what she means but then but
you're not being eliminated
you're just
getting into shape
it's the same issue actually that we
have with the transgenderism
which is
the only way
that
fat people are being eliminated by being
encouraged to get into shape is if their
identity is fatness
which is a mistaken identity that's not
who you are if you're plenty of people
are overweight plenty of people
are have some issue with their bodies
right i guess basically everybody has
some issue with their bodies this is a
fallen world it's an imperfect world
sometimes we're just born that way
you've got a thyroid condition you're a
little bit bigger sometimes through our
own habits we just we eat a little too
much we're a little slothful we don't
work out we don't and these are problems
and you can you can try to work on these
and you need to accept the natural
limits of a fallen world but okay maybe
you can improve so i know people have
lost a lot of weight gotten into really
good shape
when they were not in very good shape
before
it's not your identity
you
just like the transgender person is the
the identity of a man who thinks that
he's a woman
of stanley who thinks that he's sheila
his true identity is not sheila his true
identity is stanley
it's not the word phobia it means an
irrational fear
so you hear this about transphobia
all sorts of phobias
fat phobia it's not
not every
traditional preference is irrational
not every standard is irrational
it's not irrational to think that a
little boy who wants to become a girl
should not mutilate himself and chop off
his genitals that's not that's actually
rational to think that he shouldn't do
that
that's because there are standards we
can know things through reason
we can it's okay and and by the way to
have a standard doesn't mean that you're
saying that everyone who who falls short
of that standard is evil all men sin and
fall short of the glory of god this is
an imperfect world but if we don't have
standards to stride toward
standards of the good the true and the
beautiful not the ugly and the wicked
and the false and the you know the
standards of the left is pushing on us
if we don't have good true standards to
strive toward our society is going to
decay that's what's going on around us
and and a society that allows itself to
do that is quite irrational indeed i'm
so glad you liked that clip now please
ring the bell
subscribe
you you can get all the notifications
for our videos and then head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch your google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]